Lisa Bravo Khan is well underway have
you been able to avoid a certain group
of ladies while you're here I think it's
way Brava has arranged everything I'm
out you'd spend a little time in a
dressing room once I thought should I
just be here or am i hiding I don't know
but brother
arranged everything I've spent all the
time at Vanderpump okay that was then
this is now you know we've got a great
new season coming up that was a long
time ago I mean it was like every year
now it's great to have new faces but
their problems seem as complicated as
their predecessors woman to woman be
careful let's talk about season eight of
Vanderpump rules we have five new faces
on the cast
why introduce so many newbies in one
season well it's also you know the
people that are actually working there
and then they become kind of integrated
with the original cast so you know it's
just he was kind of up I'm ready to be
on a reality show who pops and who's
legitimately there so you know it's not
you're not casting people so to speak
you know fans are speculating though
what this might mean for the future of
the original cast it may be it's going
to turn into two shows or something
I don't know I think we just go one
season at a time and see where that
lands us I mean it's been incredible to
support and how kind of loyal people are
to the show and how exciting is I think
to see them take on new challenges and
these people to grow up but no I don't
know I have no idea that's true who
brings the drama more the new kids or
the original cast oh well you put them
all together and it's a big melting pot
you know and this one's with that one
and
you kind of watch it but it's a great
season I know that for sure there's
nothing to slur about this season
sometimes do you think what as we go
into it what's gonna happen but you
never have to worry about it because
there's always so much happening with
this group because they're all so
authentically entwine I'll tell you what
Stassi told me a little bit ago she said
it feels like the new cast watched
seasons 1 through 7 and pulled out all
the plays from those seasons I disagree
I don't think she can say that because
she wasn't around the new cast much say
most of everything that they filmed was
that at Sur pretty much I mean that's
kind of where it was based we know
something so the new cast have a dynamic
between themselves as well not
necessarily just with the old [ __ ] they
have a dynamic that was in existence all
right so you know there's always a lot
going on hey I've got 400 people working
with there's a lot going on there's a
lot going on we know there were some
friendship fall outs on this season Jax
and Tom The Witches of WeHo what
surprised you the most well I think the
intensity of their feelings
I think things got heated I think
probably things went too far but things
escalate with them and I think you know
hopefully things can be repaired but no
some cases maybe it's best to kind of
work in the other direction I know
there's so much cohesion in this group
you know there's if it's not them that
glued together then it's their
respective others you know you've got
Katie is best friends with you know
Christian and then you know so things
change all the time but there's a lot of
creation that's described it as not
friendship but relationships that's
alright yeah just like one moves they're
white they will not go and live on the
same street I don't know but that's who
they are you know they're on vacation
together you've told me before you could
film this show year-round and you want
it you really could I just don't have
the energy to do that but your time has
freed up a little bit cuz you're only
filming one show which the fans are
gonna be sad to not see you twice a week
on their TVs do you feel sad about that
well of course it was very difficult for
me but I kind of put that experience in
the same compartment in my life that was
a very sad time so the fact that I've
come out of it and I'm on the other side
of that now even though it was kind of
compounded women to please my mother
just three or four months ago it was
difficult to have my life so I'm
actually happy to have moved on and to
come out the other side because that
year was brutal for me Andy I said
though that the door's always open
would you ever walk back through that
door again you know what you should
never say never because I always said
I'd never be on a reality show so I
don't know Andy did come to see me at
the house the other day and we were
having a joke about it he's always
saying to me you know at some point I
just say it's not even up for discussion
now if you do bump into any of those
ladies this weekend what's the
conversation I know the fourth annual
gala is coming up very soon what can we
expect from the gala and our tickets
still available
I think it's sold out there might be a
couple of tickets left it's sold out
pretty much every year it's gonna be
great entertainment but it's also about
the journey it's about what we've done
with money we've raised in the past it's
about the progress we've made it's about
the sanctuary in China where we've got
700 dogs there it's about 1,300 dogs
that we have rescued here it's about
some of the struggles and it's about
showing the people thank you people
giving a great night but also showing
them you know what we're doing and you
know we just got the packed Act signed
by Nancy Pelosi yesterday which is one
books that's something with championed
you know to really stop the cruelty and
torture so if we come a felony around
the misdemeanor so all the things we've
accomplished and I'm very proud of the
work that my foundation has done I'm so
happy to see you happy
right
[Music]